it
what's on your
oh boy
by Eddie so high-level things above
well assalamualaikum warahmatullah
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends before I start when a
praise allah subhanho wa taala the most
merciful the most trust or praises glory
and gratitude belongs to him
for allowing us to convey these messages
to you and these advises with his two
lovely brothers next to me as you can
see when discussing the topic of saying
Merry Christmas to Christians and a few
other aspects as well it's not gonna be
like a fatwa
we're not giving fatwas out you know
we're not scholars but it's a general
advice and I've got here about the dude
Ian who's a revert from a background
which is Christian shanty yes yes so
basically it's good that we have Amir
cuz we're gonna be discussing that
matter in depth then we are brother Musa
he's going to be giving us a bits of his
side of his side of the story but
obviously touch up on the video now the
reason why I did this video is because
I've made a post on Facebook regarding
this matter and I just for okay you know
it's common sense you know we as Muslims
we do not say Merry Christmas to
Christians we just don't see it we
respect their religion no problem do
your religion nobody stuff in your
religion nobody's stopping you
celebrating whatever it may be but as
Muslims a consensus which we're gonna
have there's a link at the bottom of
Islam Q&A which you can check yourself
regarding the matter so say Merry
Christmas and Happy Holidays etc you can
go there and check out yourself the
fatwa is there but regarding as Muslims
we know that we can say Merry Christmas
now it was a bit shocking to me to do a
Facebook post and then find Muslims
coming to say nay were you talking about
why can I say Merry Christmas my
intentions are clean um you know I I'm
not doing it for that reason or this
reason so I was like okay Christmas is
gone and today is obviously the day
after it so I for okay hold on a second
let me do this video it has to be done
because it's sad that we have Muslims
forget say Merry Christmas
they're celebrating Christmas so
obviously like I said before I wanted to
do this video okay so getting straight
to the point Bob this is what I truly
believe from seeing those Facebook posts
what I've realized is Muslims that they
don't know what how he'd is really about
and they do not understand understand
the severity of [ __ ] because for you to
go there and act like is okay and say
marry Chris
this to me that shows you really do not
understand the severity of what [ __ ]
kids because Alice Montana in the Quran
tells us one of the biggest sins is silk
murder and zina yes I want to give you
guys an example murder yeah
if somebody killed somebody in your
family you came and killed your brother
yeah and after doing that killing he
made it a is a celebration for example
yeah and he wanted to celebrate every
year the killing of your brother and
while this is happening other people in
your family members and you go and say
for example happy killing day yeah to
you now it might sound like what the
hell what kind of a weird weird absurd
example is that murder Alice wanted to
say is one of the biggest sins yes would
you go and say happy killing day would
you do that no why because you're deeply
hurt inside cuz it was a family member
yes number two the matter of zina if
your friend came to you today and said
hey I'm gonna go link that girl or
there's this guy and I'm gonna come as
zina would you turn around to your
friend Muslim friend and say hey have a
great time would you see that you know
deep inside you will see it and find it
weird what the hell like they're doing
that I should be advising them now
zina is bad yes murder is bad what is
the biggest sin in Islam [ __ ] is worse
than anything but when it comes to [ __ ]
you say hey what's wrong with Merry
Christmas that's why I personally
believe as your brother in Islam
advising you excuse me advising you that
the matter of [ __ ] you haven't
understood it that's why he's so easy
for you to say hey what's wrong say
Merry Christmas or happy holiday but
what what would you say why why do
muslims like like i said i personally
believe it's because they have a lack of
understand about what so he did and the
similarity of [ __ ] yeah but what's your
take on it i think is that
yeah things like Muslims always feeling
the need to please yeah or justify their
own actions so because they want to
justify their own actions and because
they feel like society so against them
we want to fit into society so we're
gonna say Merry Christmas we're gonna
say this we're gonna say that they show
them when we're gonna dress a certain
way we're gonna wear certain clothes
yeah we're gonna cut a business and
we're with each other so because we have
to fit into society and especially when
true a lot of things are happening
within Syria wherever around the world
and Muslims are being made to look a
certain way yeah a lot of Muslims when
things like Christmas come they feel
they need to be normal in inverted
commas and they think that things like
Christmas are normal celebrating the New
Year's is normal but what you have to
understand is like then some Muslims
come and they give the example Oh on Eid
money but John comes to me and says
happy Eid or having isn't that what you
have to understand is when your neighbor
John says to you have a happy Eid yeah
that doesn't make him any less of a
Christian in Christianity there's
nothing wrong with that exactly in Islam
there's concepts like shirk kufur yes
you know certain things are Haram we
have those limits do you understand and
just because we have those limits that
doesn't mean that if other people
non-muslims and the majority of the
world doesn't have those limits we say
oh we need to hear that when we feel
this like void inside no fun Christmas
yes you know happens etc whatever their
Christmas yeah yeah it happens just
because the war celebrates it just
because you walk in hate your name or
next and you go Christmas sales in
inverted commas on New Year's Day or
anything like that
follow-ups are going off in Dubai
wherever and all of the you know some of
the Muslim countries that doesn't mean
that we as Muslims need to start
endorsing non-muslim activities that's
what what what is sad is obviously
there's Muslims who have Christian
families out there who are sometimes in
the diamond our eyes like it's hard to
get it now with them you can look at
them if one of them just slipped out of
their mouth and said Merry Christmas you
will say you know what maybe it was just
that cause I found it just do you get it
even though it's wrong mainly because as
it is wrong Judy I'm trying
but you can see you know what okay the
guys family is there it just slipped out
his mouth mistake okay and they might
repent Allah I'm asking my main purpose
is to Muslim that they in general who
are born to Muslim households what is
your excuse that for example if you do
not seen Merry Christmas
is it so so big that you know you will
end up being I don't know for example we
attacked by this individual like what is
it that like it like I said before it
weighs it that would affect you so much
and I want you guys to understand what
I'm about to tell you is the severity of
[ __ ] and I'm gonna give you guys a story
and this Korea this story is of a
scholar where he was teaching he was
teaching his students about toe heat
right the oneness of Allah but the
matter of sheer and he was teaching them
for a long period of time till the
students came and said o teacher like
we've learned this now committed to move
on so he said are you sure he said yes
any student said yes let's move on so
what happened is the teacher next day
comes and tests them yeah
and I want to test you guys two stories
I'm gonna tell you number one he goes
through students and says did you hear
that there is across the street in that
house a man who had sexual intercourse
with his own mother I repeat he has
sexual intercourse with his own mother
we said zina is one of the major sins
and when he students heard this they
were like what the hell he seen about
his own mother
like let's just go to talk with gyunam
saying that is disgusting so then the
share carries on and says also did you
guys hear in that house these slaughter
in the name of Allah another deity right
another God and they had a reaction as
well the spirit side of reaction as well
but the reaction of the first one of the
guys kickin with his mother was much
more worser than then the story of the
house spluttering in the name of another
God so the Sheikh said this is the
reason why you guys haven't understood
so he you guys haven't understood the
severity of [ __ ] because you have found
it more disgusting that a man commits
zina
with his own mother whereas Sheikh is a
million
times more worse than that that's why I
wanted to do this video brothers and
sisters
excuse me this the reason why I wanted
to do this video brothers and sisters
because this is how much of a sin it is
that unless one's Allah says the
mountains are about to crumble the earth
is about to open and the skies are about
to explode and we have to leave one
light this is you know what really
saddens me okay well I really really
saddens me we have Muslims like well I
mean nobody's pressing me on the guy
does all you don't even pray five times
a day
you don't give others rights you don't
even first and then you come up to
individual and say hey what's wrong say
Merry Christmas not only are you
ungrateful but now you're saying you
know what I need to please the people
people Allah I'm sorry yes I don't I
don't care
well how what kind of a disgrace or the
worst that I've seen against you as long
as the people are okay Merry Merry
Christmas
you happy you accept me what you know I
lost want Allah says in the Quran Allah
says in the Quran the Christians and the
Jews will never ever be happy until you
leave the religion now I do not mean
this in a way of all Christians and
Druze it but I'm not saying that because
Christians and Druze I have friends you
get it I have people that I know there
are lovely people lovely people and
respect your religion but I will not say
Merry Christmas and the same thing I do
want to wrap it up the same could be
said with happy holidays like I'm not
giving a [ __ ] or like I said before but
for you to say happy holiday right now
intentions just because you want to give
them dower and be kind just because your
intentions are right doesn't mean you
use the wrong means to achieve that you
get it what's the point of me saying
okay for me to get closer to this
individual this clear I need to give a
dower so let me go start chillin with a
go in now a bit closer to show a look
I'm a Muslim I'm a good person we can
chill okay my intentions is good but the
way I go about it is wrong we need to
understand that the Prophet peace be
upon him it's brought us the actions
this intentions have to be the Marshall
you got intentions but if you're
actually not according to the Sunnah it
won't it won't be accepted for me so I
so I want to play a little clip of the
Quran from surah maryam verse 88 onwards
or how Alice pantera describes
the matter of [ __ ] the severity which is
good if we're gonna play that for you
guys inshallah to be in a shape on your
hajiman whether the lapa digital change
and it the economy
some guys you heard it for yourself and
I'm just gonna repeat it
I was font Allah says in the Quran in
surah Maryam they say the old merciful
ar-rahman has got Allah has got a son
indeed you have come up with such a
disgraceful thing that the heavens will
explode and the earth is about to burst
apart and the mountains to fall down
crumbling this is your Lord speaking to
you and telling you the severity of them
claiming the Christians claiming that
Allah the Almighty has begotten a son
now do you think the Christians just
believe this that he's just a son of God
no majority of them believe that stuff
Allah Jesus is a part of Allah is
treated the chin the Trinity seen son of
God is worse saying is a part of Allah
is even worser and that's why you guys
need to understand the severity of what
you're doing so probably this is one
thing that I want you guys to understand
is you do not understand the severity of
[ __ ] because I lost want Allah says in
the Quran that the ones who died upon
shape I will never ever forgive them now
I just want to ask you guys a simple
question if you know sheikh is so bad
why would I risk committing that act
that blasphemy we always want Allah says
like I said before how severe it is why
would I risk that by just going to
somebody and say Merry Christmas when I
can avoid it
I can really avoid it so why would you
guys risk it knowing how sinful [ __ ] is
why would you risk go into somebody and
like I said before it's not like you
have your Muslim and you have Christian
family which is Oka you know your even
that scenario to say oh you're not even
in that scenario right you don't have a
problem of okay if I'm at kinship my
breakup my mom might not speak to me my
dad might they saw me etc even though
that happens that you shouldn't even
know okay just cause our positions you
should say Merry Christmas but
even in that situation but you just
think it's okay to see no Christmas but
the trillion brother drilling you
yourself your family is Christian they
celebrate Christmas yeah how do you deal
with it you get it and do you say for
example okay that the reason one bring
you in is because as a Muslim that has
Christian family members yeah sometimes
you might be cornered to be like oh you
know it's tough
did you I'm trying to say like what
would you say that would you do in that
situation
like when a family come and say to you
Merry Christmas
first of all my family knows that they
don't have to wish me a Merry Christmas
I already told him like I don't
celebrate it so I'm not gonna say it
back so there's no reason to yeah even
wish me something like that and him dela
they respect it and they even these days
they didn't come up to me wish me a
Merry Christmas so I told him that and I
think it's important to inform your
family about about these things and that
it's not it's not appropriate for Muslim
to say Merry Christmas to celebrate it
but you have to do it in a respectful
manner like in the best of manners I've
tried my best handle on my family
accepts it and yeah I think it's
important now you've let your family
know that you respect their religion or
their beliefs yeah but you don't yeah
you don't you don't what they celebrate
it with them yeah yeah sometimes and
like I said before me my video is mainly
for those Muslims out there now when it
comes to reverse just you I want to say
something is that look I don't know your
situation I don't know what you go
through
Merry Christmas I'm being honest but we
can't see it you get it if we can't see
it what your arch ring is basically have
a good day as a beautiful day enjoy
yourself associate and partners of Allah
that's what you've seen the fact that
you can see to me my intentions are not
that but I'm telling you my dear brother
and my dear sister the fact that you've
seen that that's that's what it means
and you should specifically because
kimchi breaking kinship in your family
is a big sin as well so if you're if
you're if you have Christian
you're Muslim and you have Christian
family members and there is certain
issues that you wanted to which I can't
answer to I'm not a scholar go to a
scholar with your situation and ask them
maybe they will give you some kind of a
fat one obviously no facto say no go and
say Merry Christmas but I thought -
according to your situation of what's
going on in your household which would
be better so cuz I don't want to miss
understanding where I'm just saying it's
black and white that's always when it
comes to matter of Merry Christmas yes
but regarding other things I would I'd
encourage you guys to go and speak to a
scholar and Shalala Robinson says I
don't want to keep it long and share
this video with your friends please I
really want people to be really educated
share it with your friends and let them
benefit and understand the severity of
what you are uttering instead of talking
with your whims and desires always oh ok
it's just a friend nothing bad is going
to happen so yeah that's about the
additional you guys benefit assalamu
alaikum what i've metal a better care to
have a beautiful day